playing in the uh
staying in the music in the in the music
genre
i haven't heard this yet but people keep
sending this one to me
um it's called time to act
by david robix
so i guess we'll check it out it's only
two minutes so
this guy looks like a college professor
who was let go for sexual harassment
he looks like if dave matthews put the
old filter on
i figured i'd try it out too he really
does look like that
he looks like dave matthews now just now
yeah you're right right you're right
when it's 2019 but it feels like 1933
when your eyes are open when you know
the history
when your parents live through things
that load so much like this
all the indications impossible to miss
when you suck for your whole life why do
they all think they're talented
why do they all think they're talented
why why
why why why
lived through things that load so much
like this all the indications impossible
to miss
when you've sought for your whole life
to make the earth a better place
and you once again see the rising of the
masteries
when you know that they are clearly
acknowledging it all right well hey you
know at least we went to the master
races
when they announced it in advance when
you know for many people
this will be their last chance then you
may ask the question
what can one person do when a time to
act is now
and now it's up to you
when i wake up yeah i know i'm gonna be
i'm gonna be the man who wakes up next
to you that is the song
when i go home i'm gonna wake up in the
fourth strike and we are going to purge
the degenerates
when it's 2019 but it feels like 1933
well i would kill 500 journalists and i
would
kill 500 more just to be the man who
killed the thousand jealous
okay come on detention is the new
reality
for so many children to whom you did not
give birth
when you see they're just as precious as
every other child on earth
when they're opening the camps not you
since the war
where families were imprisoned decades
before
when kristallnacht is coming they
announced it on the news when the
writing's on the wall
i didn't get the memo no you didn't it
was prying their private text messaging
app
when you can see the fuse then you may
ask the question
what can one person do when the time to
act is now
and i blame the
then she's a [ __ ] three-minute guitar
solo
joe satriani solo and now it's up to you
when it's 2019 but it feels like 1933
when you know rallies aren't helping and
silence is complicity when you know
where the kids are kept
locked inside their cells when you see
approaching
the future this foretells when they're
coming for your neighbors
when they even said what day they plan
to put them all in buses
and take them away when you know where
they keep the buses
yeah they're gonna take the buses to
portland and let them leave like
they're not rounding people up at the
concentration camp shut up
we're not that lucky you've been to the
parking lot perhaps a whole lot of
petrol bombs is the best move that
you've got
and you may ask wait wait wait wait wait
what
was he talking about making bombs or at
the end did he slip that in
what was that this foretells when
they're coming for your neighbors
when they even said what day they plan
to put them all in buses
and take them away oh dude i just
realized the title
this is this this is so this song is for
will vance the guy tried to attack the
isis that was trying to blow up the
propane tank
that with the the cop that we was
talking about it the karate chop cop
that's that's that's what this that's
why it's a propane tank
fire bomb in support of this guy yeah
coming for your neighbors when they even
said what day they plan to put them all
in buses
and take them away when you know where
they keep the buses
you've been to the parking lot perhaps a
whole lot of petrol bombs is a best move
that you've got
and you may ask the question what can
one person do
when the time you act is now and now
it's up to you
this guy's so bad these people are all
so these are the worst
kind let me see this is the kind of
comments uh
uh remember me when the crosses are a
burning
remember me when the racists come around
remember me when the tides of peace are
turning ew
yeah i'm gonna read it people are so
[ __ ]
dude this guy is really bad
really bad